good morning and welcome to sophie ridge
on sunday
i'm trevor phillips sitting in for
sophie who's away
boris johnson does not lack self-belief
perhaps inspired by the sight of a bunch
of 70 and 80 year olds still hogging the
limelight at glastonbury and in hyde
park yesterday he ruminated in public on
his plans for a third term in office
that would take him into his late 60s
this just two days after a double
thumping in the tiverton and wakefield
by-elections and two weeks after 148 of
his own mps voted to get rid of him
the joke going around westminster
already is that nobody minds if he stays
until 2030 as long as he's gone by 9 pm
political waggishness aside there's
still a full agenda for the johnson
administration
inflation into double digits a war in
europe
boats in the channel
and of course brexit still far from done
as they say in the music business the
hits keep rolling in lots to talk about
so let's strike up the band
in a moment i'll be speaking to the
northern ireland secretary brandon lewis
from labour i'll be joined by the shadow
foreign secretary david lammy
daisy cooper deputy leader of the
liberal democrats will be here
also on the program the european union's
ambassador to the uk jar valley del
media
and could royal mail workers be the next
to vote for strike action i'll be
speaking to the leader of the
communication workers union dave ward
so
so bruising week for the prime minister
and his party
let's see what plans they have to
address those big issues
joining me now is the northern ireland
secretary brandon lewis good morning mr
nurse good morning um
can we save everybody a bit of time and
just agree that you took a major beating
in tiverton and hunterton
yeah there were a bad set of results for
us that does happen sometimes mid-term
uh there's no denying it was a set of
results we we've got to look carefully
out and learn from your party chairman
oliver dowden resigned in the early
hours of friday morning saying that
somebody has to take responsibility um
prime minister said again and again that
he takes responsibility for everything
that happens on his watch why is he
still there
because actually i think one of the
things we've seen in the last couple of
days is he zest and his enthusiasm and
determination to deliver for the country
we all have responsibility for the
actions you know we're all members of a
party i was in wakefield myself we all
are delivering as a government and
working to deliver as a government what
we've got to do this has happened before
where we've seen by-election results go
one way and then a following general
election go a very different way you
can't extrapolate as you know trevor a
by-election result into a general
election result it's been proven time
and again to not work that way
we've got to make sure that we're
delivering for people so that come the
next general election they will vote
conservative to allow us to continue to
improve our country well you say that
but 148 back benches
think he's an albatross around your neck
and that was before last thursday and
the numbers are probably going to grow
now
this could this man could cost you your
majority and the mission which we'll no
doubt go on to talk about of all the
things you want to do high productivity
low tax and all of that
why
do you stick with boris johnson when he
could actually be
the main obstacle to you achieving the
britain you want well i've actually said
before on on this show with sophia and
and elsewhere that actually i think
boris johnson is the right person to
lead us into the next general election i
think he'll do that successfully i've
also i was also clear just a few weeks
ago that those by-elections are going to
be difficult by elections let's remember
we've got a difficult backdrop in both
those seats why the by-elections came up
let alone where we are with the
pressures for people seeing with that
global challenge of inflation on the
cost of living that people are
challenged with as well as some of the
backdrop we have seen within our own
party over the last period so it's no
surprise that these were going to be a
difficult set of results what we've got
to do though is make sure that we are
not just learning from those results
where of course what we saw was a lot of
people who previously voted conservative
this time stayed home we've got to make
sure by the next general election we're
motivating those people to come out and
vote for us i do think boris johnson's
the person who can do that he's proven
that time and again where people have
written him off
both before london elections and before
even the 2019 election and then we've
been able to come back and win and win
successfully i think he's got the
ability to do that i think we as a party
have got the message and the structure
and we'll have the players into the next
general election to show that we've
still got things to do to help improve
our country even further yeah some of
your colleagues have pleaded with him
just at least to change the way he
presents himself in public a bit and you
know yesterday he's talking about having
a third term before anybody's given him
a second goal i mean
he's having a laugh isn't he and that
isn't that the sort of thing that really
gets people annoyed well i think you
could look at it i appreciate obviously
trevor the way you've outlined it but
what i see there is somebody and this is
what i see when i work with the prime
minister every day but it's on northern
ireland specific issues or as i remember
the cabinet and wider issues somebody's
got that drive and enthusiasm for what
we want to achieve for our country and i
think seeing that kind of zest and let's
be friends somebody who's enjoying doing
the job and wants and has got plans for
the country that he wants to deliver
having that ability to look forward i
think it's a good thing we often get
criticized let's be friends we can often
get criticized in politics so we look
short term just the next day the next
election the next vote actually we've
got somebody as prime minister who wants
to be looking long-term at how we
structurally improve our country for
generations to come that has got to be a
good thing all right well look
let me put this to you i mean um
you and uh oliver dowden are notoriously
seen as uh
the the most normal members of the
cabinet and you've been loyal i think
i'd say that as a compliment
you've been loyal to prime minister now
three years ago dowden warned
that the tories face parliamentary
extinction in some parts of country and
she said this in the times
the conservative party is facing an
existential threat we need a leader who
can engage everywhere energetically
advocate our cause and win people over
no conservative is better placed to do
this than boris johnson now i'd like you
to compare that with what he said in his
resignation letter sent at 5 30 in the
morning on friday
our supporters are distressed and
disappointed by recent events and i
share their feelings we cannot carry on
with business as usual somebody must
take responsibility
dalton used the word extinction and what
he is essentially saying on friday is
that you face an extinction level event
you can't brush this off
well as i said you're
the top of the program look we've got to
be clear about these were a difficult
set of results for us you do get that
mid-term we've got to be focused on
delivering for people and i think one of
the points prime minister has made over
the last few days is correct us talking
about what's going on inside westminster
within a single party is never a
productive thing to do what i get from
my constituents and from people i talk
to them wherever i happen to be in the
country is they want to see governments
focused on delivering for them and let's
let's also remember trevor if you think
back even to 2017 where we had a
phenomenal set of local action results
in a bad general election you do see
differences that was only a month
between them let alone the fact that
we've had a difficult set of
by-elections here we've got a period of
time to the next general election we've
got to be focused on getting things done
to make lives better for people put more
money in people's pockets grow the
economy so we have more jobs in the
economy better skilled jobs as well so
we improve productivity these are all
things we can be doing as a country
whilst we're also playing our part on
the world stage this is an impressive
effort mr lewis but let me tell you what
your colleagues are talk looking at
they're looking at the tiverton huntsman
performance and the fact that if it were
repeated across the country
several of your cabinet colleagues
including the prime minister and deputy
prime minister would be looking for new
jobs here's who's going to lose their
seats
johnson eustis sharma
rob
um the real fear for you here must be
that labour party and the liberal
democrats work together and you face a
wipeout let me put it to you again
isn't it time
if you really want to protect the
conservatives mission
get your manifesto pledges done
the person who is standing in the way of
that is the prime minister
no actually i disagree
at a couple levels first of all most of
the people who are calling uh making
criticisms on the prime minister people
who want to see him gone because they
want to win election the labour party
the liberal democrats people who oppose
brexit initially this is somebody i
think is capable of winning a gem
election delivering for our country as
he has done in the past look i've been
chairman of our party through difficult
elections and more successful elections
as well
you cannot extrapolate as you know a
by-election result into a general
election not least of all because even
if we look at tibetan the liberal
democrat vote in itself went up
marginally what we've got to do is
motivate those people who didn't come
and vote who usually would vote for us
to come back and vote for us that's
about financially a thousand yeah as
i've said to you trevor i'm not i'm not
i'm not underscored that's a bad result
what we've got to do is encourage and
give a reason to those people in a
general election to come back and vote
for us that's about delivering over the
next year or two and then about showing
that our plans for the following
parliament are exciting plans to take
our country forward and boris johnson's
the person who can do it all right
before we get on to those exciting plans
let me just have one last batch to that
this prime minister says he's now
thinking about his third term um would
you felt happier if he said yesterday
that uh as tony blair did more or less
in in 2005
that uh he wants to be clear that this
next election will be the last he will
lead uh concert the conservative party
into and after that
he's gone
no and david cameron did a similar thing
if you remember there's a huge amount of
pharaoh around that afters what i want
is a prime minister who is not thinking
about the next few months but he's
thinking about that long-term change we
need in our country so you're having
delivery going on and on and on as they
say look
i'm very clear i want our country to
have a conservative-led government for a
very very long time i want a prime
minister who's looking at the long term
and doing so with enthusiasm and focus
that's what we've got in boris johnson
and that's why i support him and we'll
continue to all right well look let me
um
let me give up on that one to some
extent and take the prime minister's
point that um he thinks people are
harshly sick of hearing about him and
what that what they really care about is
policy on
jobs and cost of living and so on so
let's talk about how you're doing on all
that um
strikes this week uh there's probably
more coming down the track is there any
resolution to the rail dispute inside
well i hope there is obviously this is
an issue between the employer and the
unions uh but i think for for people
across the country we want to see a
resolution to this people being
disrupted getting to school getting to
medical appointments getting to work
that isn't good for the railways even
where we've seen this roughly 25 drop in
use of railways through covid as people
have had obviously pressures of covid
and coming back to work and change of
how they they work
having further pressure on that where
people start to see the railways as
unreliable is not a good thing for the
railway particularly we want to
encourage people to be using public
transport so i hope we do see an end to
this um and i think that's what's in the
best interest of the country as well you
say you hope you want to see an end to
it um
and your colleagues have been saying
this week uh this the negotiations
nothing really to do with ministers it's
between the employers and the unions um
would it be helpful if there were less
colorful language from some of your
colleagues grant chaps accused the
unions of i'm quoting here gunning for a
strike
called under false presences
uh
you're trying to turn an industrial
dispute into political showdown aren't
you no but equally i think it is right
that we as government ministers are very
clear and give a guide to the public
about what we think on these issues that
affect them this is a government of
course that's investing 96 billion
pounds into rail infrastructure we
supported the railways and actually all
of us trevor ui and everybody watching
this program put in the support worth
about 600 pound per household into the
railways through kobe to keep them going
so he's right that we air in the
opinions we hear from our constituents
and as a government around why this is
the wrong thing to do we should not be
having a strike we should be seeing this
but aren't you just giving mr mick lynch
the uh railway uh workers leader the
opportunity to
make the point that he constantly makes
but this is really nothing to do with
the employers and that the government
minister government's ministers are
pulling the strength so every time mr
shaps gets into it uh mr mr lynch smiles
and says
tell you who's in charge here but they
won't talk to us
well i think you see it's factually not
true it's the union that's calling the
strikes they're meant to be negotiating
with the employers we as a government
the ones putting this record levels in
investment into the railway services and
improving it modernizing it and i think
it is right that we're clear with the
public as i say when we've seen this 25
drop we see more and more people who do
use railways using them in a way that
uses their mobile phones et cetera so
you've got some of those ticket offices
now issuing less than one ticket an hour
that isn't a way to run a modern railway
it's right that we're putting the
investment in to support that change
just done it you've just started to
express a view about what should be on
the subject of negotiation
what i've just outlined you is a factual
position of where we are with the
railways and the development with the
railways and the government see massive
record levels of investment billions and
billions of pounds to improve our
railways for people's use in the future
for people to use it they need to be
confident in it that means it means it
needs to be reliable that's partly our
investment but it's also the unions
making sure that the railways are
running and trains can run on time all
right there's more coming down the track
uh british airways have voted for a
strike postal workers teachers doctors
even
barristers um
what's your plan are you
making it clear to everybody you're not
going to get inflation rises
look we've got to be we have been very
clear we've got to be very conscious and
careful with this is about taxpayers
money and making sure we're not doing
things that further drive inflation if
anything we want to be looking at what
we can do to hold and pull inflation
back to more reasonable levels this is a
global challenge we're seeing countries
all over the world with these pressures
on inflation we've got to make sure
we're not doing things that further
drive that at the same time as
recognizing that we as a gun want to do
everything we can to support people but
of course this is all taxpayer money and
it's right that the chancellor looks at
that very very carefully so to be clear
none of these people is going to get an
inflation level
uh
uh
pay increase none of them is going to be
in the seven to nine percent range well
there's a whole range of decisions for
different sectors and we saw nurse
obviously last year got a pay rise but
let's be very clear trevor we're looking
at a structure so for example with the
rmt and the railway workers the median
wage in that sector is about 44 000
pounds we're seeing train drivers on 56
and even 70 000 with overtime compared
to an average wage of 26 000. i don't
think many people will feel barristers
are particularly underpaid i say
somebody qualified as one a long time
ago
so i think we've got to be clear about
doing what is right for the country as a
whole and being careful with and looking
carefully how we spend taxpayers money
all right well let's look at the country
as a whole energy costs up food costs up
taxes up the increases in pension and
wages are about to be wiped out by this
double-digit inflation um where is the
good news for the british people in all
of that well these are challenging times
there's there's no getting away but what
are you doing about it
where's the good news no that's a fair
question trevor so this is a challenging
period of time as i said we're seeing
global pressure from as we're coming out
of kovid as we're seeing actually the
food pressure particularly from that war
in ukraine putin's abhorrent invasion of
ukraine is putting huge pressure on food
supplies and governments all around the
world are dealing with it so what we
have been doing is we've been putting a
very substantial package of support for
people that's worth about 37 billion
pounds so about 8 million of the most
vulnerable households in the country are
going to have support to around 1200
pounds this year alone the chancellor is
obviously carefully looking at this for
decisions that he'll be making in the
next few months around what more if
anything we can do and how we do that in
a way that really directly helps people
whether it's about keeping the cost of
fuel down and as somebody represents a
part of the country a lot of my
constituents is on all fired central
heating i understand that pressure
and we want to do what we can support
with that's why that 37 billion pound
package of support has already got it
some of which of course hasn't quite got
to people yet in july for example the
national insurance threshold change will
help people with a reduction in their
tax payments but
as you say it hasn't got there yet it
isn't
getting into people's pockets there is
still the situation where people feel uh
poorer and it's puzzling you spent 400
billion plus and covid and we know all
of that that
everybody kind of agrees that was a good
thing to do
it's part of you can't spend find
another 10 billion or so to meet some of
the pay demands that would help to
offset uh those cost of living increases
well that's the balance the the
challenge the decisions the chancellor
has to make and my economics degree is a
very very long way behind me now but
even i know trevor one of those one of
the realities of the challenge to say
we've got the national insurance
threshold change coming in in july that
will see people getting that tax
reduction across the country but what
you also find is because of what we've
done through kovid we have got more debt
in the country that we've got to manage
and the decision a chance has to make
when using taxpayers money is not
putting up debt further of course
our children our grandchildren's
generations will then have to pay off
and equally not putting things into the
economy that further drive up inflation
we want to see inflation coming down
this is a global challenge there's no
getting away from that but we also want
to be able to make sure we're doing this
within our means so that you know we
can't continue to just print money
because that drives not only further
inflation but debt for the future so
there are difficult balances the chance
has to make i think he is doing that in
a way that works for people across the
country and helps them have ultimately
more money in their pocket all right
well look um
obviously chancellor is not going to
move uh on this let's let's talk to the
talk about the dilemma and one of your
other colleagues faces faces you're
sending asylum seekers to rwanda polling
tells us is probably quite a popular
policy with a lot of people
um but you haven't actually managed to
ship a single individual to kigali um
even when people like your policies you
can't actually execute them
well look one of the things we said this
is always going to be one of the changes
we have with uh illegal immigration
sometimes is the way our processes work
i was immigration minister for a while
myself a few years ago and i can
remember having times where we were
trying to
deport even foreign national offenders
and at the very last minute and there's
a tactic that some of these people will
use where literary is on the plane they
will then get the lawyers to go and
claim asylum or something so that
doesn't mean they're going to succeed
these people
illegal these are people these are
illegal
likely to be asylum seekers you know
these are people who have come here
illegally in the case i'm talking about
sometimes these are even foreign
national offenders where they can run an
appeal at the very last moment that
means that you have to go back and start
again doesn't mean they're going to win
that appeal and it is right that we have
brought in place a policy and i think
the chance the so the home secretary and
the prime minister deserve great credit
for bringing forward a policy that he's
actually very clearly seeking to break
the business you've got the policy but
you haven't actually done it and there's
no sign you're going to be able to well
first we have brought the policy and
you're quite right the courts have
decided that they that we've got to
go through this process of this appeal
they haven't said that what we've done
is is wrong and i'm confident eventually
we will see people moving to rwanda and
it is right of course that when people
come to this country they do it in a
legal means it's not people putting
people's lives at risk and importantly
means that people here legally can get
the proper support that they need okay
look i i i'm really trying to find out
when you're actually going to get going
on on doing things now there's an
interesting thing well hold on so trevor
just be clear we have got going on this
it's not the government that has
prevented this flight from going back to
iran no but that's a court decision okay
let's deal with another uh issue which
is now the business business secretary's
uh business i understand now that the
government is considering uh putting um
neuter tariffs on import and steel um
and that will mainly affect some
developing countries now this isn't
first of all is it going to be is that
true and secondly if it is true
that's not very friendly to the
developing countries who want to export
their steel and um
for global britain which needs all the
friends it can get it's not very smart
foreign policy is it oh well we are a
global country you know as you've seen
we've been working with partners around
the world not just on ukraine but on
trade deals as well and one of the
things that the business secretary the
chancellor the prime minister have to
look at all times is getting the balance
between how we trade with our
international partners and also making
sure we give the best opportunity to uk
based industries and businesses to be
able to grow to be sustainable and to
deliver and create security and supply
whether it's for food whether it's for
energy and infrastructure here in this
country so
look these new tariffs on steel
could be a possibility i'm not saying
look i'm not saying they could be i'm
not saying they won't be i'm saying as a
government we are always looking at what
we do to get the balance right between
our international trade our work with
our international partners and what's
right for the uk
okay look let's um the deal find if i
may with your own territory um
any progress on resolving the
differences over the northern ireland
protocol yet uh well we're going to have
the legislation will be brought in for
what we call second reading the debate
will be in parliament tomorrow uh the
foreign secretary myself will be leading
that work uh through parliament tomorrow
so look i think that is the start of
seeing a resolution to the problems
around the northern line of protocol
that is going to resolve the very issues
that have been so detrimentally
effective
no we're not actually we're very much
fixing the problems within the protocol
particularly with the way that you've
wanted to see it implemented that's
caused that has caused substantial
problems for businesses in great britain
not supplying northern ireland and
businesses and constituencies and
communities in online not being able to
access the products they need even the
jewish community technically can't
practice their religion because of the
eu's requirements that's not acceptable
but you see what the problem is here i
mean we've been talking about all the
things the government says it wants to
do
uh and it feels like
at best your law lord frost described
the northern ireland protocol uh as
unfinished business um you got brexit
done
uh but you didn't actually and your
answer to the failure of the policy
it seems to be to abandon the deal that
you yourselves signed so even where you
won even where you've got the policy
this government seems to be ready to
snatch defeat from the jaws of victory i
mean
it's a government of paralysis isn't it
two things in that trevor first of all i
think that's a very unfair and a
misrepresentation of the reality of the
protocol the form of the protocol is the
way the eu wants to see it implemented
and i think actually as a as a
government it would be wrong of us to
leave a situation in northern that isn't
working there's no political leader in
any party in northern ireland who says
the protocol is working the unionist
community in northern fundamentally do
want the protocol
removed what we are doing is fixing the
problems within the protocol about how
it's being implemented so that
businesses can prosper again so people
of northern lightning who at the moment
for example can't even benefit from the
chancellor's decisions on vat and fuel
tanks that have helped people across the
rest of the uk we can't implement in
northern ireland because of the way the
protocol works we've got to fix that for
the people in northern ireland and
ultimately i want to see the
re-establishment of the north island
assembly and the executive the protocol
is getting in the way of that and that's
why it's breaching the belfast good
friday agreement we've got to resolve
that that's what this legislation will
do but ultimately we want to do this by
agreement with the eu but to do that
they need to show some flexibility and
actually come and negotiate in a
flexible way
you see what the problem is here i mean
uh the prime minister says oh stop
talking about me uh let's get on to the
things that matter but on almost
everything and i don't
challenge your good will on this but
almost everything you've said to me
yes we've got plans yes it's going to
happen but it's all jam tomorrow not
delivery today and isn't that the real
problem of a johnston administration
that talks a great game but we're still
to see the results on any of these
things and we haven't even talked about
leveling up well actually i'll challenge
that trevor because what i've talked
about today is 96 billion pounds we are
investing in our railways with the 37
billion pounds we have already putting
and are putting in to support people and
with the northern ireland protocol it's
about actually fixing the issue around
what the eu have put in place we are
doing that in fact we'll be in
parliament moving that legislation
tomorrow in the next 24 hours we are
very much getting on with the job
brandon lewis thank you very much indeed
thank you
sakia stammer should have been cheered
up by his party's win in wakefield this
week
but he's got some problems of his own
several members of his shadow cabinet
ignored threats of disciplinary action
to join the picket lines at railway
stations he's under investigation by the
durham police and he said that he will
step down as labour leader if he's fined
for breaking covet regulations
well joining me now is labour's shadow
foreign secretary david lammy good
morning mr lammy
you had
a good result in wakefield
does that mean labour's on course to
form the next government
well the result represented a 12.7
swing from the conservatives
to labor you know trevor that we won't
be forming the next government unless we
persuade people not to vote conservative
but and to vote labour that's what
happened in wakefield and if that result
was replicated across the country i
would be foreign secretary labor would
in fact be forming the government so it
was an excellent result we need to win
in those so-called red wall areas seats
that we lost in 2019 we need to pick up
right across the country very pleased
with that result on thursday
well it's great in theory isn't it and i
think you acknowledged there that though
it's a boost the chances of that
happening
nationally uh in every constituency
don't look so good for example
tiverton you came second there in 2017
and 2019 this time
the conservatives were defeated largely
because you lost your deposit um it
doesn't look to me
from these results that actually you are
on course for that victory
trevor we did well in the local
elections
we did well in wakefield the tories lost
in tiverton and yes of course there were
labour voters there that lent the
liberal democrats their votes so that
they could see the back of the
conservatives right across the story
this
this cycle
this wakefield result tibetan and in
fact the local elections are people
turning away for the conservatives so
the story of the night was this is a
very very sorry night for the government
indeed labor is on its way back and it's
on its way back for two reasons one
because we are now the party of change
in this country you've just interviewed
brandon lewis it's jammed tomorrow and
very little today for most people uh in
the country and two because we are
winning tory votes people who voted tory
now voting labor that's what we need to
do to form the next government and that
is what is happening
well you you just said a rather
interesting thing you said that um
people had lent
labour had lent the liberal democrats uh
their vote which presumably means that
general election uh they intend to uh
cash it cash those votes in and take
them back so what you're essentially
saying and
pretty much everybody uh who is expert
in this agrees with this that what we
saw this week was the return of tactical
voting
why not why doesn't labor
look at the reality
and
start to think about at least an
unofficial pact between you and the lib
dems if what you really really want to
do as you and your colleagues say every
single day is get rid of this
whatever you describe it as conservative
government
i don't think the voters of britain want
politicians to stitch up deals
uh in the corridors of power people
expect to put their uh make their own
judgment uh and decide who they want to
vote for
in the end in the 22 years that i've
been in public life it's clear to me
that we have two major
political parties those political
parties are actually a coalition
in of themselves and for the labour
party to form the next government we
have to pick up votes from people who
are considering voting conservative
that's the basis on which we'll form the
next government i see
no possibility of us forming the next
government by picking up a few lib dem
votes i've got to be honest about that
or indeed green votes and that is why
i'm really pleased about what happened
in wakefield on thursday
okay so no deal with liberal democrats
uh but at one place you are absolutely
certain not to pick up votes on the
basis of both the polls but also the
actual votes that have taken place in
local elections and so on is scotland um
are you are you ready for
a minority labor government in alliance
with the snp
well actually
we've seen an increase in our position
in scotland under and asawa really
pleased to see us winning again in
glasgow
in the elections just a few weeks ago so
i don't recognize that look in the end
trevor you're never going to go back to
where labour was in scotland come on
you were the dominant forces
that isn't going to happen
trevor trevor that's a very categorical
statement uh and and i've got to say uh
this is a matter for the electorate what
we're seeing right across the electorate
have been saying for the last 15 years
the snp will get 40 50 seats in the
house of commons i mean electorates are
pretty clear where they are
trevor i'm not going to prejudge the
outcome of an election that's likely
in two years time uh let's see where we
get to but on that result in wakefield
and indeed in tibetan
we would be forming the next government
with a comfortable majority that's what
that result tells us
so you're not telling me no deal with
the snp
now
we've absolutely clear there is not
we're not striking deals with the snp or
the liberal democrats we want to win
outright and we will be fighting for
every single vote in every single
constituency right across the country
all right well let's talk about how you
win and part of this is
what do people think labor stands for
last sunday on this program mick lynch
of the rmt told my colleague sophie
ridge i'm quoting here
i don't know where labour are if someone
could tell where labour are i'd be very
happy to hear it i think they're
triangulating between what they think is
public opinion in the light of the daily
mail and the commentary in this country
and i you know i can't do mr lynch's
voice but those are his words um
could you clarify for mick lynch i'm
sure he's watching
where does labour stand on his members
dispute and the claims particularly due
back with seven percent rise and the
demand for no compulsory redundancies
well the truth is in the name we are the
labour party
uh where a party that's always been
concerned
for working people's interests working
people who are using our transport up
and down the country who don't want to
see strikes and of course working people
working within the railways
in the end we're not in government this
is a matter for the government network
rail and the unions themselves and what
we've been absolutely clear on is the
government should be leading and
encouraging negotiations not stoking
this dispute for their own political
reasons that's what's happening it's not
for labor to determine the outcome of
this but it is for us to say get around
the table negotiate none of us want to
see hang about strikes none of us want
to
hurt people
i didn't ask you what you'd do if you
were in government i asked you whether
you su whether the labour party supports
the demands of another part of the labor
movement for a seven percent pay
increase and the guarantee of no
compulsory redundancies that's nothing
to do with it whether you're in
government or not it is whether you
support the demands of another labor
movement institution what is the answer
yes or no
well just to say i i don't want
confusion for people listening the rmt
is not affiliated
to the labour party
part of the labor movement
i've been clear trevor that it is not
for labor to predetermine the outcome of
this of course we're in a cost of living
crisis there'll be workers up and down
the country who want to see an interest
in their pay and this is not just about
pay it's also about redundancies uh it's
also about conditions there are a raft
of issues that workers are concerned
with right across the country it's not
for labor to intervene in each one and
pretend that we can negotiate or that we
are on the detail of that we aren't is
the truth of this and if we were in
government we would get around the table
we would not play union that is the
truth of being a serious opposition that
wants to eventually persuade the british
people they want to run the country yeah
i'm not asking you to intervene in
disputes i'm asking you whether you
support uh a you you said to me you're
essentially the workers party and i'm
just asking what your attitude is to the
demands of a group of workers because
you see what the problem is here it's
not that you are intervening in every
dispute but you don't seem to be uh keen
on taking a view on any of them
i i'm going to be talking to dave ward
i'm going to be talking to dave ward
communication workers union in a moment
his members have turned down the five
and a half percent offer of uh pay rise
from the post office are you gonna back
them if they ballot uh pro for strike
action
every grown-up in the country
watching this program
knows that this is a negotiation
and i'm afraid it is not always the
position that one party to that
negotiation gets what they want it's a
negotiation and usually negotiation ends
in compromise that's the grown-up
position you know that trevor i know
that trevor so it's not for me to say
yes they're entitled to that seven
percent i recognize that there's a cost
of living crisis i recognize that
workers are hurting
and i recognize they've got a government
that's not listening that i do recognize
but it's a negotiation get around the
negotiation table and fix this problem
uh so the teachers when they have who
have submitted an inflation uh level pay
rise should negotiate and compromise
which essentially means that they should
settle from a below
inflation level pay increase
let me be clear none of us
want to see our school children after
the two years they've had during the
pandemic out of school
so i really hope that we do not see
strikes across our schools in this
country i really hope that a deal can be
struck
all right
okay let's go on to your own portfolio
it's become rather fashionable to say
that
we don't know what labour stands for and
i want to give credit where credit is
due because on thursday you yourself
made a very clear statement
when which you said we are not going
into the next election saying that we
will enter the single market uh or the
eu
now um six years ago you said we can
stop this madness bring this nightmare
to an end through a vote in parliament
actually exactly the opposite um
it's perfectly right for you uh
acceptable for anybody in politics to
change their mind but i i wonder if you
could explain
when you changed your mind on this and
why
well look thank you very trevor for uh
saying that i've been absolutely clear
we are not going into the next general
election promising to rejoin the single
market or go into the eu
the position is settled you know that i
took a very strong position i was not
for brexit i was what would be described
as remainer but quite a lot happened uh
in those six years we've had two general
elections we had the referendum uh in
the first place and actually we've also
got the withdrawal agreement we stepped
out of the european union and i'm afraid
the definition of madness is doing the
same thing over and over again
the british people have made that
decision it has now been determined uh
and
there are things that we can do of
course and i've talked about financial
uh equivalency for example we need a
veterinary deal with the european union
i i want to have an association with
horizon so our science doesn't lose out
in this country so there's a lot we can
do but we're not now rehashing the
debate that we had for the previous six
years well that's that's clear that that
one's over this very very quickly if i
may ask you
will labour agree with the prime
minister that it's time to import
tariffs on steel imports to protect our
steel industry and the jobs they're in
i i saw this
emerging news
i believe in free trade it's good for
everyone tariffs is usually a bad idea i
i've only just heard this news i'd want
to get into the detail but my instinct
is this can't be right
david lemmy thank you very much indeed
thank you
this week marked the sixth anniversary
of the uk leaving the european union
and it's all going very well according
to the architect of boris johnson's
trade deal in a speech this week to mark
the anniversary lord frost said that
brexit is working and anyone who says
otherwise must have an axe to grind
but he did admit that the northern
ireland protocol remained
what he called unfinished business
well let's see if we can um get any
closer to the finishing line because
joining me now is the european union's
ambassador to the uk gia vale de almeida
um good morning ambassador um
any chance that
we might be able to resolve this problem
can you see a way through
we remain very much committed to that we
want to find a way out
i'm afraid the government's track uh is
maybe probably unfortunately a road to
nowhere and and we would like to avoid
that
when you say it's a road to nowhere you
you basically just dismissed what
they're what they're proposing i mean
uh
miss lewis has told told us that there's
going to be a new bill and
he's going to try to deal with the
practical problems and so on are you
just simply dismissing what they've
offered no we're not dismissing but we
we read it very carefully and we think
to be very frank we think it is both
illegal and unrealistic it is illegal
because it's it's a breach of
international law
a breach of eu law uk law and
international law it's a treaty that we
signed ratified and even went through a
general election in this country we also
believe it is unrealistic because it
does not provide the real
alternative to the protocol you know we
had long negotiations so trying to sort
of square the circle around the problems
created by brexit and the kind of brexit
that was chosen in northern ireland none
of us british side our side could find
anything other than this platform to try
to address those issues we are committed
to find the the practical solutions on
implementation but we cannot start
talking if the if the if the baseline is
to say everything we are that we
have agreed before
is to be put aside so so we're at
stalemate really aren't we
for the moment we are for the moment we
are but let me say that we are very
committed to finding solutions we've
been to northern ireland several times
we talk all the time to northern ireland
stakeholders as much as we talk to our
interlocutors here in london and i think
we found
solutions for the problems or the main
problems that we found in implementing
this protocol we are about to reduce our
label and willing to reduce by 80
the sanitary checks by 50 the paperwork
on people you know normally if we apply
the rules by the book a lordy that
carries different kinds of goods will
have hundreds of pages of paperwork we
have reduced it to less than three pages
per lorry
but
there has to be controls because this is
about
as much as protecting the good fight
agreement to which we are very committed
but it's also about protecting the
single market of the european union all
right well we'll watch this space um
let's turn to
one of the biggest stories still and
that is ukraine it's um announced this
week that ukraine has been granted eu
candidate status chancellor scholl so
germany says the eu's got to reform its
voting rules before it can admit new
member countries um
it feels that though it's a great
gesture the likelihood of ukraine
joining the eu anytime soon
seems rather small well trevor let's
pause one second about the historic
dimension of what we did this week in in
in brussels what our leaders agree it's
not not only giving ukraine moldova and
georgia a clear european perspective
meaning you are part of the family you
can be members of the european union it
was given
ukraine and moldova candidate status
meaning that from
this week they are candidates to join
the european union there's a long path
ahead of course if i take my own case of
portugal small country in the west in
the west of europe it took us nine years
uh to get a full membership of the
european union it implies a lot of
reforms it implies a lot of alignment of
of policies and structures and
legislation and rules inside ukraine but
the signal we're given the signal we're
giving this week is absolutely crucial
if you went asked me a year ago if
that that will be a likelihood before
the invasion before everything that
happened i would be very skeptical about
it today i'm i'm enthusiastic about the
prospect of giving our ukrainian friends
who are suffering so much this clear
european perspective well you say
there's a clear european perspective but
i think that you will understand it
ukrainians are taking this with a little
bit pinch of salt when um
the member states themselves haven't
presented an exactly united front mr
macron wants to give vladimir putin uh
concessions and it's on the phone to him
all the time as far as we can make out
germany
accused of dragging its feet over
weapons supplies
you can see why president zielinski
desperately wants to join the eu but
feels maybe the eu
is supportive
in words but not necessarily indeed we
are supportive but we are also
responsible the last thing i think we
should
provide the ukrainians with is false
hopes or false promises we need to be
realistic accession to full membership
will take time it will take effort on
the ukrainian side it will also
force us to certainly adapt some of our
structures some of our policies in order
to you know it's a 44 million people
country a large territory uh coming into
the union of course this requires
efforts on both sides but let me be
clear this was a unanimous decision and
i think it's very important to note our
countries have evolved you you name some
some of our leaders that maybe a few
months ago had more doubts than they had
this week so the the union went a long
way to address uh the the needs and the
requests and the aspirations of the
ukrainian of the ukrainian people i i
and you're a diplomat and i know you uh
would shy away from anything that he
seemed even mildly critical of any of
the eu's members but um
over the past week gas problem the
russian gas supplier uh it's it's cut
the supply through the nordstrom
pipeline by 60
um
do you think
that the russians could actually
undermine eu solidarity because
frankly the germans depend on that
bulgarians depend on on that and that
this is pressure that could crack that
solidarity open trevor let me
look back to the last few months
if if president putin's hope and goal
was to divide us if his goal and hope
was to divide nato if it was to divide
the uk from the eu on this type of
issues it totally failed we have
likely enlarged nato we have a
strengthened european union we have very
good cooperation with uk as far as
ukraine and russia is concerned and we
have adopted six packages of sanctions
you know targeting more than 1 200
people 100 entities we are cutting off
basically
the the supply of oil
by the end of the year and of course on
gas you
you mentioned get this is extremely
sensitive for our country so there's one
thing we should never do
is to apply sanctions that hurt us more
than it hurt
our main target and we need to make sure
that we we we sustain the support of our
voters
to to the sanctions so they are
calibrated they are measured but they
are i can guarantee you hitting very
hard the heart of the russian economy
all right let's turn to a story which um
we've just been talking about with uh mr
lewis and also with mr lammy and that is
a report that the
government is planning to introduce
steel tariffs to protect the uk steel
industry um some people believe that
these would break the wto world trade
organization rules um
we are staring down the barrel of a
trade dispute possibly a trade war
aren't we
well well i don't know the measures
i cannot comment on them but in general
terms i don't think protectionism is the
solution for any of our problems of
course we need to be attentive to the
rules of the game if everybody in in the
in the world trade scene is following
them or not and when we find this kind
of when we find this kind of
non-compliance we are very tough as well
when it needs be so again i cannot
comment on this but i think our
economies are facing a very difficult
very difficult times largely because you
we're just coming out of the kovitz
cycle and trying to implement very
ambitious recovery uh measures and we
are hit by the consequences of the war
which by the way are not only hitting us
if you look at the seed food so food
security situation in the world i mean
the russian troops are occupying the
fields they are blocking the ports they
are destroying the infrastructures in
ukraine and they are assuming a very
heavy load of responsibility in terms of
creating possibly a wave of famine in
the world so it all goes back to
to what's happening in ukraine and
russia that's why it's so important that
we remain united the eu and uk and we're
doing a good job on that the eu itself
nato the whole western world but also
that we bring on board countries from
the south
because this is also their concern you
um
are coming to the end of your term here
you'll be leaving moving on uh i know
that's something i think actually
i'm going to say moving on to something
even more glorious at the end of this
year that's exactly the case more
glorious
you said that you believe in life after
brexit um
that's true for britain but it's also
true for the european union yeah what
what do you envisage as the future for
this large european union with all the
strains not just the the war the ukraine
war but all the other things that are
going on
how is the eu going to hold together i
think i'm i'm i'm
maybe more optimistic than i was maybe a
couple of years ago what i've seen in
our reaction to brexit where we stayed
united
no other country even
thought of considering leaving and
public opinion support has
been strengthened if i look at the
reaction to kovid where we
we were together responding to this
crisis and responding in terms of
recovery if i look at ukraine situation
i was even surprised let me say very
clearly by by by the boldness and the
and the strength of our response to to
create so if i if i take this uh very
recent crisis which we dealt with with
in a in a very solid way i'm positive
about the union but we will have always
to adapt to new circumstances it's a
it's a it's a living animal and that
that's what makes it so fascinating
ambassador thank you very much for
joining us thank you i wish you well in
the next phase of your distinguishing
i'm still here for a few months
thank you very much indeed
now
the liberal democrats are in buoyant
mood following their dramatic win in
tiverton and huntington honniton
the talk of election pacts is in the air
with what's been described as industrial
scale tactical voting in this week's
by-elections
maybe it's time to prepare for
government again
maybe
joining me now is daisy cooper the
deputy leader of the liberal democrats
good morning
good morning congratulations on tibetan
uh your vote shared jumped pretty
dramatically uh it says hero by over 38
percentage points um do you expect to
repeat that as a general election
well first of all um the result in
tibetan and hunterton was a historic
victory for the liberal democrats we
have just achieved overturned the
biggest majority in a by-election ever
in british political history so of
course we are indeed buoyant when it
comes to the next general election we
are hoping to win seats off the
conservative party we are the key
challenges in many places across the
country and we're working very hard to
get as many of those suits as possible
yeah you didn't do it on your own uh did
you um actually you you were able to
turn that performance uh because labor
basically uh went off the pitch and lost
its deposit
well actually the reason we won tivot
and hunting was because not only did
labour voters lend us their vote but
thousands and thousands and thousands of
former cons former conservative voters
who are quite frankly sick of a prime
minister who is breaking the law and the
government that has no plan for the cost
of living crisis they also decided to
vote for our candidate um to be a strong
community champion for tiveton and
honniton and they chose to vote for us
because we are setting out a plan as to
how to tackle the cost of living
emergency that is facing families up and
down this country mr lammy uh told me um
a few minutes ago that um you should be
happy because labour people lent you
their vote but he implied that they were
going to take him back uh we've been
here before haven't we big lib dem uh
wins in by-elections in between and then
the seats go right back
well if you look at sarah only seat for
example in south london she won her seat
in a by-election and she's still an mp
today i think what we're seeing is a
strong pattern we saw in chechman
amisham in buckinghamshire and then in
north shropshire now in devon the
liberal democrats are winning seats off
the conservatives with very large
majorities and the reason for that is
that this conservative government does
not have a plan and the liberal
democrats do have a plan we are in the
middle of a cost of living emergency
people up and down the country can see
that the conservative government is
sitting on its hands whilst liberal
democrats are putting out practical
ideas as to how to tackle it but you'll
understand why viewers will be a bit
puzzled by this um
both you and labour people come on this
program and you say the worst thing in
the world is a continued boris johnson
administration but the one thing you
will not do is uh have a pact or any
kind of alliance or even an
understanding which would guarantee that
there are more tiverton and honetons
between you and that the tories get
pushed out
explain why that is so impossible and
you know the argument that voters don't
like it
either you believe voters don't want the
tories in or
there's some other reason why can't you
guys get together
i think there's a really big distinction
between a hypothetical situation that
may or may not happen in a couple of
years time and the reality of what we're
facing right now as an opposition mp i
can see day in and day out how the
inaction of this conservative government
is hurting families in my constituency
and around the country and that is why
right now i can look at the conservative
government and decide i want them out of
power i want them out of office and
that's why liberal democrats are putting
forward these concrete ideas like the
windfall tax like an emergency va t cuts
like a winful tax on bankers bonuses we
are the party putting forward these
ideas to tackle the crisis that is
facing people right now i i didn't hear
in that answer a rejection of an idea of
an understanding
well that's because we're talking about
hypothetical situations it's not
hypothetical everybody knows that if you
did what you did in tibetan and honest
and you'd you'd win lot more a lot more
seats you haven't said we won't do it
well liberal democrats will continue to
try and win seats off the conservatives
in the sea in areas where we are the key
challenges the fact is if you look at
the last two years things have changed
so much nobody had expected the pandemic
or anything else we simply can't work
out what will happen in the future all
right well let's let's um imagine that
there might be a liberal democrat
component in a future government you'd
have to deal with the sort of thing
that's going on this week uh strikes
your transport spokesperson condemned
the government for making
uh i think the quote was no effort to
stop these strikes um what would your
effort be how would you tackle this
i think it is extraordinary that with
the threat of strikes and of course
there is uh threats of a summer of
strikes as well in any other time with
any other prime minister a prime
minister would have used the power of
number 10 to get people around the table
to knock heads together and to thrash
out a deal we have a prime minister who
is missing in action we have a transport
secretary who just admitted that he
hadn't
met with the unions for more than a
month i think many people are very
sympathetic to the fact that there are
people on low incomes
who are really struggling with the cost
of living crisis and they recognize that
this government hasn't done enough and
they recognize that frustration but but
i don't i don't agree with the strikes
but i do think the government should be
using its power to get people around the
table so the liberal democrat policy is
that tried and trusted 1960s policy beer
and sandwiches at number 10 ministers
sitting with unions and employers
knocking heads together getting a deal
which mostly meant the taxpayer funded
it
so what we have suggested is actually
there should be an independent public
sector paid body that can look at this
issue right across the board for the
public sector it works incredibly well
with the low pay commission that sets
the national minimum wage i think the
same thing could be done for the public
sector as a whole that would take the
politics out of this issue and it would
get a fair deal for people who are on
low incomes and struggling with the cost
of living daisy cooper thank you very
much indeed for joining us this morning
thank you
well we journalists love a good cliche
even if it's more than 40 years old so
we've dusted off the summer of
discontent as union leaders do battle
with employers over pay and jobs
we've had a week in which the rail
network virtually ground to a halt on
tuesday ballot papers go out to more
than 115 000 postal workers over its pay
dispute with royal mail
joining me now is dave ward the leader
of the general uh the communication
workers union morning dave um
what exactly
are you asking the royal mail and bt
bosses for
well it's about getting a pay rise that
recognises the impact of the cost of
living crisis
it's also about recognising the efforts
that work as all of our members there's
we've got disputes going on right across
the whole of the union at the moment
um
that you know recognizes the efforts
that have kept these companies going i
mean the background to this as well as a
cost of living crisis
is the reality that bt posted profits of
1.3 billion last year royal mail 758
million
they paid shareholder dividends of 700
million and 400 million respectively and
i think what's making workers more and
more angry
is that the ceo of bt his pay has
actually gone up by 32
in the last year in role now
the financial director
apparently hit all their targets and got
1.5 million and the ceos just received a
bonus of uh 140 000 pounds
so you know people are saying i think
enough's enough i want to come to all of
that in a moment but let's let's talk
about what it will mean for people who
would be watching this program
uh last week they couldn't get to work
because of the trains um that it looks
like they won't be able to fly on their
summer holidays so now actually if
somebody
sends them a parcel they won't be able
to get that either it's pretty miserable
isn't it well i think our job is to
represent workers um
and what i say to that to anybody
listening to this is that you know we
have a simple message which is you know
every worker counts or no work accounts
and of course you know going on strike
is the last result you know we do that
when negotiations have felt
and we will be you know once we've done
our ballots we've got our bt ballots
that we announced the results of on
thursday as you said postal workers over
115 000 will be receiving their ballot
papers on tuesday um you know we'll be
making it public that we want
negotiations to resolve those disputes
so the objective is never a strike
um but this is this is a moment i think
and i hear the the message that you said
about the summer of discontent i mean
obviously the people who are trying to
create that image
uh
is the is the government at the moment
and you know i think people across the
uk
have sort of seen through some of these
tactics so what i would say to you is
this is if people look at the financial
crisis 2008 the pandemic uh the cost of
living crisis the climate crisis the
only certainty
in the uk at the moment if we don't make
a stand for all working people
is that the rich are going to get richer
and the powerful getting more powerful
and that's what we've got to address in
the uk including in how the economy
operates
just
well let's come to that in a second but
am i to understand that you really now
expect
that bt workers when balloted will
probably
reject any offer that's on the table and
that we're heading for industrial
election
with bt
well we didn't get a chance to reject
their well the union rejected their
offer our members
in bt across bt group never got a chance
because the same guy who increased his
earnings by 32
phillip jansen the ceo imposed
a pay deal of 1500 pound on the
workforce in role now they've imposed a
pay deal with two percent
the these things are unacceptable so
stale mail's off and email's going to be
for
you know whatever bt communications uh
represents um
the ceo of royal mail admits that his
workers deserve a pay right pay rise
he's put two percent uh on the table
five and a half percent uh on the table
as well
is it reasonable to launch industrial
election
uh
against somebody who actually
sympathizes publicly with your members
well
it's reasonable to make a stand for
working people and our members will be
the judge of the actions of the ceo
i have a different view of the way that
they are behaving at the moment um i
think if you look at you know it's the
same tactics it's about trying to divide
workers
the the issues for us at the moment in
the uk and you know i repeat this this
is for all workers in the uk
is that this can't carry on you cannot
continue
to talk about leveling up to talk about
modernization when all of the proposals
that these companies come forward with
are actually leveling down
uh work the lives and the living
standards of working people it's not
acceptable you're in a slightly
different position to some of the others
uh
disputes teachers and so on because
you're
your your people work for private
company
isn't the problem here that uh you want
these pay demands to be met
but the royal mail ceo says he needs to
remain competitive in a tight market and
isn't it the case that if you win your
demands people are going to be happiest
won't be your members but the bosses at
dpd ups dhl fedex tnt and all the
competitors because royal mail prices
are going to go up they are going to
soak up the business and your members
will lose jobs
let me be absolutely clear this is not a
debate about affordability
both bt and royal mail group could
afford to pay workers more money they
say no um well they can this is simply
not true
i've just given you the numbers they
choose deliberately to put other
arguments on the table now this argument
about competition
uh and effectively that we should just
accept the race to the bottom
um i think that's
a point we've reached a point now where
we have to challenge that argument and
that's why the tuc which hasn't been
picked up by the media is also running
the campaign at the moment which all
unions have signed up to and how union
led this campaign for a new deal for
working people and a new social
settlement in the uk and i think you're
going to see that support for that grow
during the course of the summer well it
looks as though actually there's a lot
of this going on across the union
movement um your colleague uh mr mick
lynch who's become a sort of television
and uh social media star and indeed do
you have had some things to say i think
about the labour party's support or lack
thereof for uh your dispute mr stama
secure ordered his front benches to stay
away from the rmt's picket lines some
chose to ignore it but and i talked to
mr lammy this morning he wouldn't commit
himself on any of the disputes either
the rmt or indeed
yours um
how do you feel about the level of
support you're getting from the labour
party
well first of all
my answer to that is it's time for
unions to step up now community
organizations and run our own campaigns
and not rely
on any political party to solve our
problems and i think that's going to
increasingly be the reality of the
situation
when it comes to
you know the government i mean they're
picking a fight
um they've chosen the side they're
coming out because like they're doing
everything to try and divide working
people i don't think that's going to
work i think they've miscalculated i
think labor have miscalculated because
i think they're obsessed with you know
reconnecting with working people
and
you know the reason that people moved
away from labour was over brexit i don't
think people are going to turn their
backs on working people
who are facing these challenges because
we're all genuinely in that together and
i think labour have miscalculated um
it's up to kierstama what he does but
what we're going to do
is reach out to
working people across the uk
uh in communities coming together to
really bring about serious challenges
you're pretty hacked off with load parts
aren't you
i'm disappointed um but i don't let it
get us down you know i don't rely on
i've been around too long trevor to rely
on politicians to solve problems for you
this is a moment where trade unions
community organizations we all need to
step up and we need to shift the balance
of forces in the world of work in how
the economy operates and across society
dave ward thank you very much indeed for
your time thank you
two by-election defeats and the surprise
resignation of his party chairman
but it doesn't seem to faze the prime
minister despite his rather cheerful
admission yesterday that he had stuffed
up
however it may well reignite chatter
among some conservative mps about mr
johnson's leadership
joining me now is a conservative
commentator tim montgomery good morning
tim
boris johnson said yesterday that he
didn't think there was much chance that
he'd be changing his behavior any time
soon or indeed his psychology well
you've worked for him and with him and
you know him do you agree with his
self-assessment
i'm afraid i
do think that he seems pretty committed
to carrying on as he has done for quite
a while you mentioned trevor that i
worked for him very briefly and it was
very briefly it was um just before the
2019 election and just afterwards and
i saw uh in the brief time that i was um
working for him an awful lot of
dysfunction in downing street a lack of
structure
um a lack of direction and i suggested
to him put a proposal to him that he
brought in a former
white house chief of staff or someone
who'd run the australian prime
minister's office to carry out a wide
sort of spread review
of how his downing street was run to get
ahead of the problems that i could see
coming
and he simply wasn't interested in that
sort of um reorganization i think he
he thrived on chaos in some ways as as a
child um and he is still likes really
some sort of chaos around him really is
it allows him to rise above it and so
i'm afraid i don't really see any great
potential for a serious change of course
so you you're basically saying
this is the nature of the beast
um and i think you now regard him pretty
much as an albatross around the neck of
the conservative party um
do you think there's anything
that can be done to get that albatross
to drop i mean rather prayer and
repentance are clearly not going to be
uh enough
on offer here are they
i think the conservative party will get
rid of the prime minister before
the general election i was surprised by
the scale
of the rebellion in the vote of no
confidence that took place to think
about two weeks ago
but the thing that surprised me more was
as i went round westminster the
westminster village around the houses of
parliament in the days afterwards
the number of tory mps who came up to me
or i had a cup of tea with who'd voted
for boris johnson in that leadership
election who were nonetheless determined
in due course
to oust him now some of them had
supported him because they weren't aware
that there was a they were still waiting
for a credible alternative to emerge
which is a huge question
others are fully aware you've just had a
very interesting discussion with a union
leader who is determined to bring chaos
really to britain as other union leaders
are i think a lot of tory mp is aware
that these next nine to 12 months will
be difficult they don't want the new
leader to have to be in place during
that period better to get the new leader
in after then
and so at some point because of a
variety of reasons tory mps will
will get rid of it they just weren't
sure a couple of weeks ago was the right
time to do so
you mentioned there the uh
obstacle in many people's minds that
there doesn't appear to be an obvious
successor um can you see one
i can see
a number of candidates that would be
good prime ministers and i think nearly
all of the candidates can you name one
or two
uh happily i would think that um sanji
javid would bring confidence to the job
i think that dean zahawi would bring
great unity to the job i think tom
toughenhart would bring a clarity on
foreign and security policy i think all
of them uh all of the main candidates
would bring a sort of sense of direction
and unity and moral sort of leadership
what they have to convince all of us is
to
give more details show that they have a
team around them because what the
conservative party can't risk is going
from
one
failed leader to one who isn't ready and
so there needs to be mechanisms in the
in the party over the coming months to
test the possible candidates and ask
some searching questions and we all know
trevor that behind the scenes they are
all maneuvering and i think it's time
that they're a little bit public about
it
but more public about it so that they
can be held accountable and we can ask
them the sort of questions that we need
to to find out if they're ready
tim thank you so much and i i hope that
between us we haven't wrecked anybody's
chances by naming them but anyway we
shall see
that is it for this week uh sophie ridge
on sunday great fun to be back for a
little uh for a moment after a break
we're going to run through today's
interviews and see what we've learned in
the take with our political
correspondent rob powell stay with us
[Music]